In Sudan, Colonel General Omar Zein Abedeen...
...says the military will not extradite deposed president Omar al-Bashir,...
...but will try him at home before the nation.
Meanwhile, protesters demand a civilian government.
In the United Kingdom, the UN human rights office urged judicial authorities...
...to ensure that Wikileaks founder Julian Assange,...
...currently in British custody and the subject of an extradition request from the United States,...
...gets a fair trial.
In Pakistan, no group has claimed responsibility...
...for a bombing that has killed at least 16 people and wounded 30...
...at an open-air market in the southwestern city of Quetta.
In Algeria, protesters in Algiers are marching for an eighth straight Friday...
...to demonstrate that they are not satisfied...
...with the departure of longtime President Abdelaziz Bouteflika...
...and want more political change.
Finally from Indonesia, hotel guests evacuate after a 6.8 magnitude earthquake strikes Sulawesi.
There are no immediate reports of damage or casualties.